hey my name is Tommy Delvecchio
DiBenedetto and I was Jerry Epstein
security guard at the Metropolitan
Detention Center a lot of people online
are trying to pin this on the [ __ ]
Clintons let me tell you man
they're good [ __ ] people they love
this guy they visited him three times
this week in the middle of the [ __ ]
night because they didn't want to make a
big deal out of it cuz they're [ __ ]
humble you should have seen Hillary
Clinton when she saw him it was like a
[ __ ] dog that it just you know when
their owners in Iraq and he comes back
she just [ __ ] lunged at him she went
right for him I had to [ __ ] pull her
off him she was so [ __ ] excited they
[ __ ] loves each other sometimes
that's what happens on suicide watch
people come in suicide that's why they
call suicide watch the players man they
gave a [ __ ] about this guy they're like
a [ __ ] family I mean the night he
died they were here praying with him
they looked like they were drinking like
wine is some dark red liquid in a
chalice and they were all [ __ ]
chanting in the shell together
it was [ __ ] beautiful I didn't even
know why it was [ __ ] in here I
thought it was like he hired some
illegals you know because he's got like
an all-inclusive in the Bahamas but my
friend said he had underage girls in
there and I said you know my cousin had
that [ __ ] problem but you know what
he did he found a girl that looked young
but was really older [ __ ] you know those
girls that like look for team but
they're 40 you go see their face it's
like real rough their skin by the
creases of their mouth is like raw well
you know you don't [ __ ] with your
Donna you know I [ __ ] love you you
saved that man's life it wasn't a bad
dude Jerry honesty you know he's not a
bad [ __ ] doing